- I said to my colleagues one
day in the editorial room,
"Why do we seem to have
a double standard?"
And there was a
terrible silence.
And I realized at that moment
that I'd crossed a line.
I had no idea what the line
was or why I'd crossed it,
but I realized I'd
stopped being one of them,
and I'd become one of you.
(energetic upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and
this is the Rubin Report
as always guys click that
subscribe button on YouTube.
And don't forget to tap
that notification bell.
So you're alerted
of our new videos.
And joining me today
is a journalist, author
and columnist for The Times
of London, Melanie Phillips,
welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Thanks Dave, very
good to be with you.
- I'm glad to have you.
'Cause I mentioned to you
right before we started here
that for about two years,
I've been getting emails
and tweets and Facebook messages
and all sorts of things.
People saying, "You gotta talk
to this Melanie Phillips."
Now you're in Jerusalem now,
but you also split
time in London.
For my American audience
that may not know you,
can you just do a little
Melanie Phillips 101?
A little bio before we get into
the specifics of your work,
your writing, your speaking,
your books, that sort of thing.
- Sure, sure.
Well, I am a British Jew,
born and bred in London
of parents who were themselves
born and bred in London.
Had a fairly conventional
upbringing of the type
that British Jews
in the 1950s had.
Parents, not very religious,
not very observant,
but nevertheless belonged
to an Orthodox synagogue.
I went to Oxford University
and read English literature,
which fits you for
everything and nothing.
And fell into journalism.
I was trained though
in those days,
journalists were
actually trained and
we were taught things
like objectivity, and
the need to be truthful,
and the needs to be factual,
and the need to separate
fact from opinion,
would you believe such a thing?
And I spent two years learning
all these trade crafts
on a local newspaper.
In Britain we have
national newspapers,
we don't have syndicated
columns like you do.
But I learned a local newspaper
in the suburbs of London
and then went to a magazine
and then went to The Guardian.
The Guardian is a bit like The
New York times, but more so,
it is the kind of
journalistic crucible
of left-wing
thinking in Britain.
And at the time
that I went there,
I didn't ever really consider
myself to be left-wing,
but 'cause I wasn't
very ideological,
I consider myself
to be a liberal.
Now I know that the word liberal
means something different
in America from Britain,
but what I meant by that,
what I mean by that,
was that I thought of myself
as an old fashioned liberal.
That is to say
somebody who believes
in making a better world
by prioritizing the good
that people do over the bad,
standing up for the vulnerable,
against abuse of power,
standing up for truth
rather than lies.
And at that time I
thought that my colleagues
at The Guardian and in the left,
that we were all
on the same side
and we can talk
about this in detail.
But nevertheless, over the
next few years I realized that
this was a big mistake, and
the while I still believed
in all those things, they
were on the other side,
they were the people who
actually were the oppressors
of the poor and vulnerable.
They were themselves
racist and antisemitic.
And during this period,
which took 10, 20 years,
I changed also in the sense
that I became more aware
of my Jewish background,
my Jewish identity,
it became more important to me,
and I became very, very
aware of the enormity
of the big lies being
told about Israel.
Would you believe I'd
never been to Israel
and never wanted to go
until about the year 2000.
The year 2000 was the
first time I went,
and I didn't particularly
like it for various reasons.
And then within
two or three years,
I had bought a
place in Jerusalem,
because my life and my
whole view of the world
and my view of myself
as a British Jew
had completely changed.
So that's a very short
thumbnail sketch of my descent
from being the kind of
a wise child of the left
to being the she-devil of
the Western Hemisphere.
- Yeah, well, I'm not sure how
much you know about my story,
but I think a lot of
my audience is going,
"Dave, we've kind of
heard this before,"
because that in many ways,
although we're, we're
not the same age,
we're not from the same country.
The story that you just
told of coming from the left
from a largely Jewish
secular family.
I mean, it's very
much the same story,
and I think in many
ways our politics
and the way you laid out,
what true liberalism is,
really do line up.
So can you talk a
little bit because
I get this question constantly.
Now, can you talk
about when and why
you started to see the split
within the left towards
socialism, progressivism,
whatever you wanna call it,
versus the liberalism
that you just described?
- Yes, well, there was one
particular punctuation mark,
which really set
me on this path,
and it was in 1982 and it
was when in a conversation
with my colleagues
at The Guardian,
I was an editorial writer
and I thought of them
as being just like me, a
liberal in the best sense,
committed to truth and
reason and decent people.
And we had a conversation
in which I was very troubled
by what at the
time seemed to me,
to be the disproportionate
attention,
being paid to what Israel was
doing in its war in Lebanon,
which was a controversial war,
but it was being portrayed
falsely as a war of aggression.
Whereas I knew,
and don't forget,
I'd never been to Israel and
didn't really want to go,
and it wasn't really my thing,
but I knew that it
was trying to root out
the Palestinian
Liberation Organization,
stop it from
attacking Israelism,
the PLO at that time
was in Southern Lebanon.
But it was being represented
falsely as a war of aggression.
And at the same time out
of the woodwork came,
unbridled antisemitism
that we British Jews
are all considered to be
basically all sticking together
in a clannish kind of
way and defending Israel.
And I was very troubled by
this and I was very troubled
by the fact that The
Guardian was spending
such a disproportionate
amount of its time in hurling,
terrible obloquy at
Israel over all this.
Whereas at the same time,
president Assad, the father,
the current president
Assad had caused a massacre
of his political opponents,
something in between 15
and 40,000 of his opponents
were killed over the course
of a couple of weeks.
And that story didn't really
have much traction
at The Guardian,
and I couldn't understand I
was different person then,
didn't really understand
what I was dealing with.
And I said to my colleagues,
one day in the editorial room,
"Why do we seem to have
a double standard?"
And there was a
terrible silence.
And I realized at that moment
that I'd crossed a line.
I had no idea what the line
was or why I'd crossed it,
but I realized I'd
stopped being one of them
and I'd become one of you.
And they said, "Well, of
course, as a double standard,"
after all they said
to me, "Like you,"
and I became you and by
you, they meant Israel.
And I never been to Israel.
"Like you, we in the West
are brought up to believe
in the sanctity of life,
respect for human rights,
human dignity, whereas people
in the developing world
are not brought up to
believe any of those things.
And so if they kill people,
we cannot judge them
by our standards,
that would be racism."
And I thought, "What?"
And I said to them,
"What are you saying?
That if one is unfortunate
enough to be born and bred
into the developing world,
then one does not then
have the same rights to
life and liberty that we do,
to my mind, that's racism."
And they said, "Why
are you so upset?
We do you," and I
became you again,
"The great honor of assuming
that you are like us.
You have the same
moral standards as us.
And what's more you tell us
that you as the Jewish people
are morally superior to us."
Now that is A, untrue and
B, it is sheer antisemitism.
And at that moment, I realized
that the assumption I'd made
that we were all marching
under the same banner of truth
and freedom and decency
and all those good things
that was untrue, that I was
marching under that banner,
but they were on the other
side, they, the liberals,
the left, the people
who assumed that
because they were the
liberals and the left,
they embodied virtue,
and everybody who
was not the liberals
and the left was a
bad and evil person.
They were the racists,
they were the antisemites,
and they believed in lies
and they were irrational.
And from that moment,
I realized that there was
a difference between us.
I couldn't any more
trust anything they said,
but because I was very
attached to the left.
And because I hadn't quite
worked out in my mind
what had happened here, it
took me a while to realize
that we were on different
sides completely.
And how I realized it was that
I was writing as a columnist
in the mid to late 80s
onwards, about issues,
a poem, which I fill up with
a left on every single one.
So the first was 'Education'.
The second was the
'Breakdown of the Family'.
The first was the
'Breakdown of Education'.
The second was the
'Breakdown of the Family'.
The third was the 'Development
of Multiculturalism'
and the erosion of the idea
that the Western Nation State
was something that you
should be proud of.
And then we went from
there into 'Islamization',
and then into all
sorts of other stuff,
and issue by issue that liberal
world just fell in on me
from the moment I
started writing that,
I became considered,
I was told I had overnight
gone mad, insane.
And overnight I had
changed my personality,
like a kind of chameleon
into being right wing,
very right wing,
ultra right wing,
extremely right wing,
fascist, neofascist.
And then as I started writing
about Israel, Zionist,
a warmongering Zionist,
and then a warmongering
Zionist insane right-wing Jew.
And that's where I
kind of ended up.
- Oh man, there's so much here.
It's like hearing my
story just a, you know,
20 years in advance or
something like that.
But so much of
what you're saying,
I think is what now in 2020
millions of people worldwide
have woken up to.
So I have a couple of
followups there first off,
what do you think is wrong?
And I hate to say this
as someone that's still
considers myself a liberal
in that true sense,
do you think there is an
inherent flaw in liberalism
that has allowed
leftism and collectivism
to basically decimate it?
So that there are
very few people
at this point in the
West, certainly in America
who described themselves as
liberals the way we're talking,
about it most of these, anyone
listening to this right now
would say, "Oh, they sound
mostly like conservatives.
I probably come
off a little more
on the libertarian
side of that."
But do you think there
is an actual flaw
in the good sense of liberalism
that allowed this monster in.
Perhaps a protection
that conservatism has,
that liberalism doesn't have?
- Well, the fundamental
flaw in liberalism
in the way that it's
been developed is that...
Let's put it this way,
there are different
types of liberalism.
There's the liberalism,
which comes out of,
I would say conservatism
or other conservatism
is a kind of defense
of liberalism.
If you look up the, one of
the greatest philosophers
of what's called conservatism,
Edmund Burke in
the 18th century,
now he's called a conservative.
But what he reacted against
was the French
Revolutionary terror.
He understood that
the French Revolution,
which was supposedly all
about freeing the individual
and introducing the rule of
reason, divorced from religion.
A whole lot of other stuff,
but that's broadly
what it's about.
It led directly to terror.
So he reacted against
that, and as a result,
he was called a conservative
and he's still a
called a conservative,
he's called one of the
fathers of conservatism.
But from where I'm standing,
he was actually defending
liberalism, he was different.
What was he defending?
He was defending
tolerance, and freedom,
and progress and reasoning.
These are all things which
I associate with liberalism.
Now liberalism has
a fundamental flaw,
it is that it has two
fundamental flaws.
One is that because it
prioritizes the individual,
it has been
interpreted over time,
and now in our
current time to mean
that you can't then
establish any kind
of hierarchy of values.
You can't say that
one set of values
is better than anyone else's,
because that's kind of being
nasty to somebody else.
And consequently, the
logical flaw in that
is that if you can't say
that anyone's lifestyle
or culture is better
than anyone else's,
then you can't say
that liberalism
is better than anyone else's.
And consequently,
you can't defend
the fundamental liberal
values of freedom of speech,
and tolerance of
other points of view,
and freedom of religion
and all those things,
which make a liberal
tolerance society.
You can't defend them,
you can't defend the
equality of women.
So when faced with say,
the Islamic world
as a liberal today,
you cannot say that the West
is better than
the Islamic world.
Even though it is, because
surely the enslavement of women
must be worse than
freedom for women,
and equality for women.
So that is one of the
essential, I think,
contradictions in liberalism,
that means that it's sort
of going down the plug,
plus the fact that it's
become a libertarian ideology,
that is to say it's taken
the notion of the dignity
of the individual and
respect for the individual
in my view is at the
heart of liberalism.
But in my view, that can only
be enshrined by paradoxically,
a body of laws and moral
values that are regarded
as kind of binding on you.
But if you detach the
individual from those laws,
then you get a kind
of free for all.
And once you have
a free for all,
then it's everyone out
for him or herself.
And then you have the
strong dominating the weak,
and then you get to a
situation very fast,
which is where we've got to,
where you don't have
a liberal society.
You have a tremendously
illiberal society,
and that's made even
worse by the fact
that this kind of liberalism
or I would call it,
libertarianism is
actually an ideology.
Now what's an ideology?
An ideology is where
the power of the idea
must trumps everything else.
You can't ever say,
the idea is wrong.
So if you come along with a
load of facts and you say,
"Well, this idea is wrong
because here are the facts.
Here's the evidence
that shows it's wrong."
Well, the ideology
says, you must be wrong.
There can be no challenge
to the ideology.
And so you have to be stopped,
you have to be suppressed,
because the ideology
of liberalism is that
it's bound up with the
betterment of humanity,
the perfection of the world.
So anyone who stands against
that, isn't just wrong,
they're actually evil,
and if they're evil,
they have to be stopped.
And so you have this
phenomenon in which
we have people who
purport to be liberal,
who are stamping out free
expression on our campuses,
preventing people from speaking,
which is absolutely
the absolute antithesis
of true liberal values.
And that's the
paradox of liberalism,
it's become an
illiberal ideology.
- Melanie, you would
absolutely love my book.
So I'm going to get your
address after and send it to you
because I'm making many
of the same arguments
and that connection between
between truly being liberal
and having something
outside of yourself,
which I think we're gonna
get to in a little bit.
But I wanna back for a second,
because you said
that you grew up
in a secular Jewish
household that was similar
to most of the
others in the 50s.
Can you sort of describe
what does that mean?
And one of the questions
I get all the time now is,
what happened to the Jews?
How did the Jews
all become lefties?
When the left has become
so rabidly, anti-Jewish,
anti-Israel, anti-liberal
all of those things.
I mean, I think you
can probably trace
a pretty clean thread on that,
but can you first describe
what did it mean to grow up
in a secular Jewish household?
Because I think that
confuses some people
and then sort of the road
that that takes us on.
- Yeah, well, to make
people even more confused,
it wasn't what I would
call strictly speaking,
a secular household.
I mean, certainly a highly
Orthodox observant people
might well call it that.
But, I didn't think
of it like that.
My parents belong to
an Orthodox synagogue,
they went to synagogue
three times a year,
the two days of Rosh
Hashanah and Yom Kippur.
We did not observe the Shabbat
in that my parents worked,
they were modest people,
they had to work,
or they felt they had to work,
but we were kosher really
kosher at home and out.
And we had a Friday night meal
with candles and Kiddush and,
you know, I didn't go out,
but we had the television on.
It was that kind of upbringing.
And, you know, my parents
they were modest people.
They weren't educated
people, but my mother was,
she had a kind of
religious instinct
and she had very, very
strong moral values,
which I came to
recognize in later years
were actually Jewish values.
But, you know, I was
when I was a little girl.
I remember every night,
she said the Shema with me,
the fundamental prayer
of the Jewish religion.
She said it with me every night.
So I wouldn't describe it as
a secular Jewish household,
but it certainly, wasn't a very
observant Jewish household.
Now what happened to the Jews?
Well, you see,
there's a difference
between the Jewish
community in Britain,
and the Jewish
community in America.
Jewish ministry in
America, as, I don't know,
you said you, is not
only mainly Democrat,
but the same proportion
are non traditional
non Orthodox Jews.
And in America, it seems to
me, the prevailing and wisdom
of the Jewish
community in America,
who are the majority
and the majority
of them are not Orthodox,
is to assume that's
the secular ideology
we've been talking about,
which actually is anti-Jewish,
it's fundamentally
anti the Hebrew Bible.
It sets out to undermine
all the basic presets
of the Hebrew Bible.
The American Jews, the 70%
who are progressively minded
or secular, they've
told themselves there's
a Jewish values.
They've kind of
squared the circle.
They can be good Jews
and believe in stuff,
which is basically anti-Jew.
Now that's disastrous
for American Jews.
I don't need to tell you,
but in Britain it's
very different.
In Britain, something
like between 60 and 70%
of British Jews have for the
last several general elections
voted for the
Conservative Party.
They are not the
equivalent politically,
your Democrats at all.
But they voted for the
conservative party mainly
through their sort of
pocket book, really.
But they have at the same time,
like so many
conservatives in Britain
and so many
Republicans in America,
they've kind of absorbed
like a kind of osmosis,
the prevailing
liberal and wisdom
about a whole range
of cultural issues.
But they're not very political,
they're not very
ideological at all.
So they're quite different
from American Jews.
However, the rates
of assimilation
in Britain are pretty awful.
You know, more and more
people are just dropping out
from Judaism, altogether,
or, belonging to
progressive denominations
where their children
marry out non Jews.
And they themselves drop out.
But it's more a
kind of a process
of sort of
demographic attrition,
rather than the
embrace of an ideology,
which is actually
inimical to Judaism,
which is I think
what characterizes so
many American Jews.
- Okay, so there's
many directions
we could go from there,
if we were to sum up
everything we're talking about,
when you see what is happening
across the world right now,
and how liberalism
has sort of failed.
And what that then
probably leads to
is sort of some version of
right wing authoritarianism
or something like that, if
you agree with that premise.
What can we do if you want
to save liberalism right now?
What can people do?
- Well, it's this paradox,
again, that to save liberalism,
you have to be conservative.
And I do believe
that the problem
that the sort of death
throes of liberalism
have been caused, not just
by the what's happened
to the left or the progressive
circles in the West,
but by the fact that the
people who are supposedly
to who are supposed to
be defending the West,
against this onslaught,
have thrown in the
towel a long time ago,
largely through ignorance.
There are not precise parallels
between British conservatives
and American Republicans,
but nevertheless,
there are certain,
I think, constant
characteristics,
but the conservative
wing of politics,
if I can put it that way,
(clears throat)
has forgotten what it is
in business to conserve.
And especially, I think since
the fall of the Soviet Union,
which I think was taking place
before the Berlin wall
actually fell, you know,
the Soviet union
clearly was, you know,
in its death throes for
a long time before that.
And I think that
what happened was,
that conservatively
minded individuals
or conservative politicians,
the conservative
political class,
when the Soviet Union
fell, it sort of thought,
"Oh, our fox has been
shot, what do we do now?
We've won."
Here is, you know, the Soviet
Union having disintegrated,
is no longer a threat,
everyone's bought
into the market.
Now, the problem
with conservatives
is that they tend to think
entirely in terms of economics.
They don't think in
terms of culture,
they don't understand what
Edmund Burke understood,
during the French Revolution.
It's all about culture,
it's all about values,
it's all about moral values,
they didn't think like that.
And they haven't
done that for years.
So they thought, "Well,
what do we do now?
Everyone's bought
into the market,
what are we going to
hang our hat on now?"
And they alighted upon freedom.
And I remember this
happening at the time.
And I thought, "Oh
no, they've had it.
This is ridiculous because
the left hung its
hat on freedom."
So what happened was that
while the left venerated
and worshiped the shrine of
personal individual freedom.
Freedom to do exactly what
I like, behaviors I like,
had the values that I like,
and no one can tell
me that I'm wrong.
Conservatives said
that everything that's
good in the world
is going to be delivered
by the free market.
And consequently, the
conservatives did not realize
what was happening on
the cultural front.
They didn't realize that
education was being redefined
from the transmission
of a culture
down through the generations
to teaching your children,
that your culture
was fundamentally
illegitimate, racist,
and should be obliterated.
They didn't realize
that was going on.
They didn't realize that the
freedom to junk your husband,
the freedom to have a
baby without a father,
even without the baby
even knowing who his father was,
and perhaps you didn't
even know who father was.
That that freedom would
come with a terrible cost
to the child and to the
woman and also to the man.
They didn't figure all that out
and all sorts of other stuff.
So they just lost the plot
and then having vacated
the cultural battleground,
they then observed that society
was changing in that direction.
And they said, "Oh, we can't
do anything to stop this.
It's like Knute
holding back the tide.
We must go with the flow
of cultural change."
And so they became
part of the problem.
And that's why
liberalism was allowed
to become the kind of
monster that it has become,
which is illiberalism
or as somebody
who was a very
distinguished thinker
once coined the term
and it's so true,
cultural totalitarianism is
what we're living through.
- My friend, Michael Malice
who's a brilliant
political thinker,
he's more of like
a anarchist type,
but he says that conservatism
is just liberalism
at the speed limit,
which I think is partly
what you're getting to there.
Do you sense that something
has shifted though?
Because I do sense right
now that it's partly
because of Trump may be
90% because of Trump,
although maybe Trump is
just a symptom of it,
but that conservatives
have started
to understand the cultural part.
I think there is a sense
of, if you look online,
the things that are fun and
funny and the memes and comedy,
the left has destroyed
all of these things
through it's totalitarian view,
and the things that are
actually interesting right now
are things that are coming out
of more right leaning circles
do you credit Trump for breaking
through that thing in a way
that the conservatives would
have never done otherwise?
- I think the election of
Donald Trump was the outcome
of a change that had
already taken place.
That is to say, I think that
there were two shoes that fell.
That's not the right
metaphor in 2016.
One was the Brexit
vote in Britain
and the other was the
election of Donald Trump.
And on both occasions,
I think what happened
or that obviously they're
very different phenomena,
different countries, but they
were fueled by the same thing,
which was that the vast
bulk of ordinary people,
the millions and millions
and millions of...
when I say ordinary people,
I mean the kind of people
who don't have typically a
higher university education,
and who had spent
decades being preached at
and being scorned and being
vilified and being traduced
by the intelligence here,
which dominates completely
the universities and the media
and the whole
cultural operators.
And more than that,
dominated politics
because even so-called
conservatives,
the Conservative
Party in Britain,
the Republicans in America,
didn't really differ that much
in this cultural
issues from the left.
And they were all basically
saying to the people,
"You don't know what
you're talking about.
You're just rednecks,
you're just stupid.
You don't even have a
university education.
You're bigoted, you don't like
immigrants, you're racist."
So the things that
ordinary people value,
which is community,
which is the attachment
to their country,
patriotism love
of their country.
And the kind of
instinctive understanding
that a country and a
culture is made up of people
who share your own values.
They don't have
to look like you,
they can be different
color faces from you.
They can be a different
ethnic backgrounds from you,
but at some important juncture,
they share the most
important values
of that society
and that culture,
which means that
you're all basically
sharing the same
cultural experience.
You're all attached
to the nation.
You all understand
what it means to you.
Now that understanding
that cultural attachment
was vilified as
racist and xenophobic
by virtually the
entire political class.
And when Brexit happened, it
was this monumental revolt
by all those millions who said,
we've been given a vote now,
and we can now use this
vote for this issue.
We want our country
and our culture back.
And they voted to leave
the European Union
and restore Britain as an
independent democratic nation
governing itself for the
first time for decades.
And when that happened on
that morning of that vote,
when I woke up and realized
that that vote had happened,
I had two thoughts.
The first thought
was, "Oh my goodness,
there is a chance that Britain
can survive after all."
And my second thought was,
"The intelligence here
will never allow it to happen."
And for the following
three years,
we have this titanic
fight in Britain
to reverse the Brexit vote.
And then a few months later,
the election of
Donald Trump happened,
and then America it seemed
to me your intelligence
or your political class had
a very similar reaction,
but rather more, I would
say violently expressed
rather than were
extremely expressed.
But nevertheless,
the same thing,
how could this have happened?
This can't be true.
This can't have happened.
The people are stupid.
The people got it wrong.
We have been robbed of
our natural inheritance,
which is a democratic
presidency in eternity.
And they didn't understand
and would not accept
that the people
had got it right.
The people wanted
their country back.
They wanted, again,
the rule of law,
they wanted immigration
to be enforced
so that they would
again have borders.
That meant something
without borders,
you cannot have a nation.
They didn't want
their cultural values
trashed the whole time.
They didn't want to
be told that America
was the rogue
state of the world.
They wanted to be
told that America
was the exceptional
nation again.
And that America stood
for values of which
they could be proud of
which they would want
to have other people emulate.
That's what they wanted when
they voted for Donald Trump.
Now, what ever you think
about Donald Trump,
whatever you think about him,
that is what people voted for.
And, you know, ever since we've,
you've had this
tremendous fight,
this tremendous fight to
get that man out of office
by hook or by crook,
and it's the same thing,
it's the class who feel that
not only are they entitled
to rule according to their own
lights and their own values,
but that it's a kind of
offense against nature
that they shouldn't do
so, and they have to,
they have some
kind of moral duty.
They feel they have a moral
duty to reverse Brexit
to get Trump out of office.
And so that's where we are,
the fight is
absolutely still on.
And who knows how
it's going to end?
I do not know how it's
going to end obviously.
And also I think that, you
know, even if Brexit happens,
I say even if, because
even now, I'm not sure,
although it looks
as if we, you know,
Britain is going to finally
slouch off the embrace,
the deadly embrace of the EU.
Even if president Trump
were to get elected
for a second term, I
would not be confident
that the West would survive.
But at least there
would be a chance.
At least there'll
be a chance because
if the left gets power
again in America,
or if Britain were
not to be able
to become an independent
self-governing nation again,
be no chance, no
chance whatsoever that
it could ever reinstate
these countries
and the culture they present
could ever reassert
themselves totally.
- Yeah, got it, it's a
dire warning, but you know,
I'm basically with
you, this is it.
It's sort of like the
grand fight all the decades
of indoctrinating youth
and destroying institutions
and everything else, it has
sort of all led us here.
Can you talk a little bit
since you're in Jerusalem,
why does Israel always end up
in the midst of
this conversation?
That the left has you sort
of hit on this earlier,
but the left has this sort of
obsession with this country,
that's the size of New Jersey
that until the last couple of
years had no natural resources
and fights for all
of the liberal values
that they purport to believe in.
Why is there such an
absolute obsession
with that tiny place?
- Well, I think there's
a number of reasons.
First of all, in the last
four or five decades,
the educational systems
of Britain and America
and the West in general have
been pumping out this message
that the West is bad, and
the developing world is good.
The developing world
can do no wrong.
The West can do no right.
Any bad things, the
developing world does
must be the fault of the West.
Allied to that, is
the fact that the West
is supposedly colonialist.
And that I think
laid the groundwork
for what must be one of
the most spectacularly
successful propaganda exercise,
isn't the whole of history?
Which was when Yasser Arafat,
who was then the leader
of the Palestine
Liberation Organization,
traveled to the Soviet Union.
And there concocted
with the Soviet Union,
the fiendish propaganda
exercise in which,
what was the truth,
which was the Arab world
trying to exterminate
the State of Israel,
because it did not want a
Jewish state there at all.
Transform that fact into the
lie that the Palestinian people
were being oppressed and trying
to shake off their oppression
by Israeli colonialism.
And from that lie develop
the historical lies
of Middle East history, which
effectively wrote the Jews
out of their own history.
And because of the intellectual
and moral bankruptcy
of the intelligentsia, which
swallowed all this rubbish,
because it came from
where it came from.
And because it told a
certain narrative story
about the evils of the
Western colonialism,
all the rest of it.
This has become enshrined
as unchallengeable truths
and unchallengeable dogma,
so that's one reason.
- Can we just pause
there for a sec?
I hate to have to ask
you to do a little bit
of a history professor
kind of thing.
But you know, when
people look back
and they see the British
mandate of Palestine,
although they usually drop
the British mandate part,
they think, "Oh, that means
that there was a State
of Palestine for a people
known as Palestinians.
And what they mean
generally is Arabs."
Now I know, you know, that's
obviously all not true,
but could you try to do
like a two minute recap?
Is that remotely possible?
Just to unpack
some of that stuff,
because what people
don't realize is,
it was the Jews that
were living in Palestine
and the other Arab nations
were boycotting Palestine
and all of that stuff.
But can you give
some version of that?
Because I think this is
where people look at a map
and they go 1947, it
was called Palestine.
And now there are people
called Palestinians
that say was home where the Jews
come from something like that.
- Yeah, okay so...
- This is probably the
most annoying question
I could possibly ask.
- Yeah, okay so history
of the middle East,
the Jewish people
standing on one leg,
or sitting on one leg perhaps.
The fact is that Palestine
was the name given
to the Jewish kingdom
of Judea by the Romans,
when they overran
the Jewish kingdom
of Judea and drove the Jews out.
They wanted to completely
exterminate any memory
that this had been
a Jewish kingdom.
And so they called it by an
insulting name Palestina.
Now it wasn't then called
Palestine over history
when the British turned up
after the First World War ended,
and with the great powers of
the time, France particularly,
carved up the Middle
East into new countries.
It was the Ottoman Empire,
they were carving up.
And what we now
think of as Palestine
was actually part of
the Ottoman Empire,
it wasn't called
Palestine in as such.
But it was then called Palestine
because that was the piece of...
that was the area that
was in contention.
And in carving up
the Middle East,
the great powers decided in,
well, what happened was in 1917,
the British government
at the time,
which was full of what are
called Christian Zionists.
That is to say Christians
who very much believe
in the redemption
of the Jewish people
in the land of Israel,
they understood that this
was their ancient kingdom, and
they should come back to it.
And they passed something
called the Balfour Declaration,
which committed Britain to
work for the restoration
of the Jewish
homeland in Palestine.
And after the end of
the First World War,
when the Middle East
was being carved up
by the great powers.
They in trying this
in international law
and gave Britain a
mandate to run Palestine
in order to facilitate the
coming the end gathering
of the Jews to their
ancient homeland
and to establish
there in Palestine,
a homeland again for the
Jews to reestablish it.
And the reason they did that,
was enshrined in
various statements
and acts of at the time
that the Jews were
entitled to this land,
not as a matter of privilege,
but as an absolute right, why?
Because it was only the Jews
for whom the ancient
land of Israel
had ever been their
national kingdom.
And so it was only the Jews
who were entitled to return
and only the Jews who would
be given political rights
in that homeland, other
ethnicities and peoples
would be given, who were
living there, i.e. the Arabs
and many others, would be given
civil and religious rights,
but the political
right, that is to say
it would be a Jewish homeland
would go to the Jews alone.
And what happened
then was that Britain
had this internationally
binding duty
to bring the Jews back into
establish the Jewish homeland,
but the Arabs who were incited
by what we would now
call Islamist extremists,
who were kind of
invented around that time
in the sort of political way
that we understand them today,
basically started to
attack and to murder
and to commit pogroms against
both the Jews and the British,
and to cut a very,
very long story short,
the British kind of
threw in the towel,
and decided that the only way
they could solve this problem
and stop their own people being
killed and stop the killing,
was to divide the land.
So having been given this
internationally binding duty
to bring the Jews in and
establish that homeland
in what was called Palestine,
which consisted by the
way of what is now Israel,
the disputed territory is
called the West Bank and Gaza.
The Jews under international
law were entitled
to settle all that land.
So the British basically
rip that up and said,
"We'll give part of
that land to the Arabs.
You can have an Arab State
alongside the Jewish State."
And the Jews said,
"Okay," and the Arab said,
"You must be joking,
we want the Jews gone."
And that has been the story
of Israel and the Arabs
from that day to
this, time and again,
the Arabs being offered
a state alongside Israel
called a Palestine State,
a State of Palestine.
Time and again, at every on
every one of these occasions,
the Israelis, the
Jews before them,
before that it was
Israel have accepted
on every one of these occasions,
the Arabs have not
only rejected it,
but have redoubled their
attempts through terrorism,
through war, to obliterate
the Jewish State.
That is a story in a
nutshell of the region.
And it's why when you realize
that story and you know,
there's a lot more to that story
than I've been able to give
you in this little nutshell,
you realize the magnitude
of the big lie about Israel.
And then you realize
something else,
that if so many people
have accepted this lie,
then it follows that they
really cannot distinguish
between truth and
falsehood at all.
Or they are really
gullible and credulous
and stupid and irrational.
And that explains quite a
lot about why the left is
where it is today as well.
- Yeah, I had historian Neil
Ferguson on who I'm guessing
you're probably familiar
with from Stanford.
And he said something
to that effect also
that it's just the biggest
lie that they sort of use
to then promulgate sort of
the rest of their lives.
So I have one more for you
with all of this in mind,
which is, are you hopeful?
You know, when you mentioned
that the morning of Brexit
that you had those two thoughts,
you sorta lit up for a second,
because I think it was
the realization that,
you know, we the people
actually do have some capacity
to control our lives
and may be the elites
and the intelligentsia
and the rest of it,
don't automatically own us.
And I think a lot
of people right now
are just completely
worried that our countries
are slipping away and
all of this stuff.
So are you hopeful, do you
consider yourself an optimist?
Are you a pessimist?
Are you somewhere in between?
- I have to tell
you, in all honesty,
I'm not normally considered to
be a little ray of sunshine.
I'm normally considered to be,
you know, Mrs. Apocalypse Now.
- I've seen some the clips.
- Until Brexit Trump
happened in 2016,
I was totally pessimistic.
I thought, you know,
the West had had it,
it was, you know, there was
no way that it could survive,
given all the things that
like we've been talking about.
And then these two
things happened.
And then we have this
tremendous fight over Brexit
over Trump, still going on,
who knows how those fights
really are gonna end.
And subsequently we had a
whole lot of other stuff of,
you know, different
kinds of uproar,
different kinds of
unprecedentedly,
awful events that none of us
could imagine living through.
And so we're in a state of,
at the moment where, you know,
the world is kind of in
uproar and it's up in the air.
But in this uproar, you know,
we don't know how the pieces
are actually gonna fall, but
certain things are happening.
I think that, as I say,
whenever you think Mr. Trump
and I have reservations,
I have to say,
significant
reservations about him.
I think that the fact
that he has shown
that America is
back in business,
that it is not going to
be a passive bystander
to evil in the world,
which can threaten America
and threaten Israel.
But it's actually going to take
a stand against bad people.
It's going to take a stand,
so he took a stand
against Iran for example.
He did not, you know,
he very much renounced
the whole craven business
of appeasing Iran,
which was basically
leading the world
to a completely
nightmare scenario.
And still is Iran
is still there,
it still poses a
terrible threat.
But the fact that he showed
that he was not prepared
to go along with that anymore.
And the fact that he showed
that he was not prepared
to stand by and allow Israel
to be endlessly blackmail
in the way that
has been blackmail
and America and the
West have stood by
while it's blackmailed
all those decades.
And that has changed the
dynamic in the Arab world
in a way in which we would
never, even a few years ago,
we would never have
thought possible.
The Arab world now
needs Israel and America
to help it defeat Iran.
It believes that it
can't do it without them.
It believes that with president
Trump in the Oval Office,
America will remain
true to that intention.
And so that immediately
changes the whole dynamic
vis-a-vis Israel, so from
that point of view alone,
that is a source of
considerable optimism.
That's not to say it's gonna
be plain sailing at all,
or there won't be terrible
bumps along the way,
or the Iran won't suddenly
go completely berserk
and do terrible things.
But it does mean that there's
more optimism than there was.
And on the cultural
front similarly.
You know, the
onslaught by the left,
the onslaught on
freedom and on decency
and morality and
truth, is accelerating.
No question about that, the
madness of identity politics
veers from one lunacy to
another, but they're losing.
And, you know, the more
desperate they get,
the more extreme they get.
And the more extreme they get,
the more you know that
they are getting more
and more desperate, and
why are they desperate?
'Cause they have
suddenly not suddenly,
but they have been
forced to acknowledge
at some part of themselves,
that the lie they've
told themselves that,
you know, everybody is with us,
and only a few fringe fanatics
Neo Nazis white supremacists,
racist, xenophobes, and so on.
Only those people
are against us.
It can't hold anymore, because
millions, millions have voted
for Trump and millions
voted for Brexit,
and millions in
Europe are saying,
"We want our nations back."
Now, some of that is not
going to result in stuff
that I would approve of, I
think you alluded yourself
to the fact that some of this
is producing leaders who are,
who come from
noxious backgrounds,
whose views may well still
be obnoxious, you know,
and some of it may turn out
to be not very good at all.
But there is a prospect
that, you know,
decent people standing
together can now win through.
In a way that was inconceivable
just a few years ago.
So whether that makes me
an optimist or pessimist,
I'm not quite sure.
- I always say I'm a
world weary optimist.
I think that we got
a little bit of that
right there from you.
Well, listen from one
far right extremist,
whatever you wanna
call me to another,
I've thoroughly enjoyed
this, I'm glad we did it,
and I hope we can do
it in person sometime.
- I hope so too, I've
enjoyed it enormously.
Thank you very much
for having me on.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out the full episode playlist,
they're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.